it's a pleasure from RL hellos to
Stephen pelican focus on the one thing I
find boring but still have to do it have
a problem concentrating on stuff that
must be done I warned him yeah that's a
good one RL um you know I'll be honest
probably some of this sort of attitude
you know things like tax returns and the
administration and the red tape and the
company registration all that sort of
stuff honestly has probably not the most
exciting thing in the world but you got
to do it there's some parts of the
business you just have to do know there
you know regulatory compliance all that
sort of stuff you just got to do it got
a tick the box and you just got to get
done my view of that is never leave till
tomorrow what could be done today so
because you and I know if you leave it
you leave it again you leave again you
spend more time worrying about it and
you could have been that time you
worried about it could have done it they
just crushed it coulda knocked the ball
out the pump so anything like that
anything you think I don't like doing
that whatever it is I'd say bring it
front and center it's really critical to
building value in your business do it
now just crack on do it and um the other
thing is always with these things once
you've done them they never seem as bad
as they were eliminate animate delegate
delegate I don't know the context of
what he's doing that it feels he needs
to do but our challenger do you
absolutely have to do it if you do then
can you automate it right if you hate
doing bookkeeping and tax returns and
all that stuff get software right that's
sage like that should be one of the
easiest first decisions that you make as
an entrepreneur is you don't want to be
spending your time and an Excel
spreadsheet in putting the stuff in
right to spend a low amount of money to
then be able to save you time and put in
something high value right there's tons
of ways that software can help so
eliminate automate and delegate right if
that actually has to be done and there's
nobody else you can give it to so
there's no soft we can give it to and
hire somebody part time the first guy
hiring with one hour a day do stuff for
me that saved more than an hour of my
time of day and you want the hire a
full-time person meeting also expensive
I can't afford
hard time there are people who do a part
time work to help you get it done the
interesting I've got Nancy Harris whose
are fantastic country manager of Canada
if she's just organized for me to meet
tons of accountants and bookkeepers who
are partners of us it's interesting when
they start a business particularly it's
a really good thing to get one of the
accountants connected because not only
do they do all the stuff that you know
keep your business whole pay your people
that's and stuff but also they give you
nuggets of advice they've seen a
thousand businesses before they know
what startups goes through they never
pain they know the cash flow issues and
they can give you good counsel they
could be a great mentor to as well